tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj pedaggi siccome domenica
siamo tornati su la scorsa domenica
ragazzi non è uscito è più il penso che
si stesse per scatenare la terza guerra
mondiale visto che tipo uscivo di casa e
la gente quando fai è più il trans così
giuro nel senso che non posso vivere su
questa impensate che tristezza di vita
che giacciono per giocarlo tutte le
domeniche se mpa una domenica senza sta
merda almeno non ricordate però che devo
farlo alla domenica prova spinning wheel
cena in sé perché 99 soldi perché c'è
una sedia di testa casa vi faccio
aspetta che ce la faccia ce la faccio
mai uk minchia complimenti lei prese al
volo ma è luke fai vedere che sei meglio
di moretta complimenti non con le
ginnaste v che farà il bagnato sport
giorno e devo prendermi prendere l'albo
la prendo io
gg niente aosta pare impossibile da
prendere ma cazzo faccia prenderlo
cc porca [ __ ] che stop ma gli operai
scusami volevo stoppare la palla
capiscimi avevo le mie esigenze resisti
che ce la fai lo so che può resistere
mi piace la sto facendo da solo da solo
vabbè fermi farmi che questa incredibile
aveva è morto però è stato un bel
tentativo sono rimasto solo io sono io
il pallone forza sa bene cos'è sta roba
perché ci faccio mosse di danza a caso
voleva vedere se riesco a vincere io
però me lo sento e questa volta buona
ieri che cazzo eventi fitness tipo tipo
la sala massaggi avete presente figata
alla madonna superman
guardalo e vabbè dai se la testa non è
necessaria credo di riuscire anche senza
mio dio
cos'è sta roba che sony quadrati adesso
ho vinto jolo
vabbè dai ragazzi giochiamo la serie a
sta cosa la casa non è possibile bravo
luke questo era un colpo decente posso
farmi anche la palla sei pronto a questo
deve andar bene perché male tanto lui
non serviva tanto è un ragazzo inutile
quindi va bene così
forza sia la puoi fare credete perché
sta vincendo
oh mio dio mentre saltava mi è entrato
al seggiolino nella schiena come è
possibile solo se tutto sul seggiolino
[Musica]
ragazzi come sono diventato un bambino
ma come cazzo
abb è giusto sempre mettere i seggiolini
in macchina che sono sicuri original
minigame cos'è sta roba
greg dell'ogm del relays del re italia
veramente ho vinto kat occhio quasi
arrivato alla fine senza neanche capire
com'era livello c'è veramente un genio
ma non ce la farò mai più
lo sapevo io bravo all'inizio mi è
uscito adesso mai più ma sono convinto
proprio posso che puoi far di meglio
[Musica]
c'è barbara la gloria di quest'uomo
quale come contento di aver vinto ninja
fight ninja fi facciamo questo ancora
che bello che sono ma se si vede che ti
sto tizio è veramente figo ascolta è di
de bravo e questo non è il nuovo gillet
per fare la barba gillet il meglio di un
uomo sentite e mi fate capire perché
sanno face perché si muovono tutti il
collo a ritmo che cos'è starò di ha
trovato un ciccione sei contento eh beh
la tizia che sta facendo pesci ma sono
tutti scemi
[Musica]
no no e mi spiace e non esiste che cosa
fa voleva li calpesta la faccia
infatti mettere i piedi in testa dopo
schifo e cosa non si fa per la patata
schifoso fratte ce la puoi fare però
l'amore di più alti ho dovuto salvare io
perché è in una situazione orribile
survive mine addosso proprio vero che
c'è scritto arca merda
ma chi è convinto no dai prova a farne
una un po mia figlia come l'ho calciato
ronaldinho si è fatta ce l'ho fatta
corso como non è possibile mi sono
esplosi tutti nel culo ecco perché c'è
il culo di ferro bravo zio outlast
transplant un trapianto di cuore
figo come fa cagare si riveli workshop
car test forma e si prestò estorto devo
andare all'altro ma perché da destra
verso sinistra che cosa strana però
potevi farlo dall'altra parte scusami
cazzo cambia se hai un problema con le
pietre aspettano rai e non aspetto io
impegno perché io con la macchina posso
impennare non so per quale motivo però
avere sì mi chiamate bella sta macchina
cena ferrari ragazzi no no devi è bravo
parcheggiato parcheggiato scusa non mi
spiego parcheggio così non ti volevo
dire però però non sa quando prendo la
patente
devo far vedere questi video a scuola
guida wrecking ball run primo che cos'è
con miley cyrus
ah no devo in volta insomma ormai vecchi
in pausa la collega sull verticalmente
dicendo ragazzi che ormai io collego
l'avrei kimball a miley cyrus cioè per
me l'avrei kimball non è più la palla da
demolizione per me è mai vista infatti
mi sa che era meglio miley cyrus almeno
con la testa ci sono arrivato va bene
poltrone verso all'indietro
vabbè mica già difficile davanti tre
palle che non è quello che pensate
che è successo ma è morto anche luke
fantastico come faccio a farlo
recentemente statica al contrario è
impossibile e bel bello sto la nemica mi
è piaciuto troppo rock swing come questo
fa livelli a cai cos'è un livello cep
son certo livello in un altro livello
fantastico ragazzina ci mancava al rock
swing
però ho vinto già qualcosa
mai nessun ebbero in da cavour cazzone
ma in su e per questo sarebbe prato
fiorito 1 ma veramente ma che figo
riusciti a fare per me ne faccio pagare
a prato fiorito c'è questo piccolo
dettaglio che non so se trascurabile in
teoria quanto ho capito ci dovrebbero
essere due bombe vincino io non lo
capisco proprio ferito impossibile non
sono capace sono 10 min e come faccio
sapere dove sono che ne so io
qua [ __ ] tua sorella alla madonna tre
cene bastava una dio mio come 3 watt da
santo dio come faccio a sapere dove sono
una qui per forza no qua non c'è ragazza
affanculo l'odio sto gioco di merda
fucka che affaccia cagare normalmente fa
cagare anche così l'ipo faith viper ben
per biscotto viper biscotto è una cosa
seria questo gioco bene va bene e che
ora da ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo livello
visto piedi miei livelli ce ne sono
pochi fa temere di belli se riuscite che
negli ultimi episodi voglio fare solo i
miei livelli fighting game questo bello
che non non c'è anche di figo non
importa ragazzi fate mi devo cliccare
walk ha quindi è un livello che clicchi
e fa le cose che che clicchi 15 ha idee
ciao zio aspettati venga uccidere ciao
erano funziona sono tarocche mai dato da
sciatta ricchissima player 26 serio sa
ancora quanti spasmi e devo dio
sai calmo faide ciao zio e sono forse
morto non sono morto mischiate il film
senso di star ho neanche con uno ciak
sono morto sono a 90 e sto camminando
ancora ragazzi non ho capito se ma cos'è
per quale motivo spiegate certo quando
hai ucciso un giocatore clicca qui per
vincere ma io non ci se nessuno e
piccolo stesso
quanto sono ribelle va bè ragazzi basta
stronzate devo uccidere qualcuno cioè
folletto praticamente in poi c'è ma io
posso saltare anche ma perché che c'ha i
poteri posso volare posso portarmi su
due persone attaccate dal culo no non
posso farlo però in compenso posso
volare con steve ma che figo cosa ho
schivato regga il gioco davanti perché
non me lo fa uccidere
è un peccato a [ __ ] tutti fantastico
basta uno contro culo grazie gaia conto
strano giocare sti livelli ogni volta
che mi scombinano la vita dove cazzo è
finito si è bloccato da qualche parte
dove si si ci sei ragazzi abbiamo perso
steve pazienza qualcuno andrà di trovare
non mi piace per ritrovare estive
ragazzi che abbiamo bisogno di lui sennò
non possiamo andare avanti e che siamo
al novantaquattresimo episodi sono quasi
al centesimo cazzo se arriviamo per
forza ragazzi storia vito vi sia
piaciuto come se vi è piaciuto sotto un
commento è un mi piace anche a pace di
facebook e come vita totale iniziale 6
saresti discreti ci davano prossimo
video